hello
how are you back in March these two
strangers met for the first time in an
airport arrivals Hall oh bless you let
um Andrew help you with your bags you
can see the relief and awkwardness as
Elona Le Meja escaping the war in
Ukraine was welcome to the UK and then
into Sarah headley's home
now Elona is not just a guest the two
have become close friends
that one's pretty looking past that
initial six month mark
would you be happy to keep alone and
living with yeah of course yeah for as
long as she needs
I think it would actually be really sad
when you do leave it would be really sad
and how's it been living with Sarah and
her family oh to be honest I'm very
lucky with this family really
um I'm the lucky person over 90 000
ukrainians have found refuge in British
homes but with no end to the war in
sight some hosts are facing extremely
difficult decisions
have something oh oh fantastic
when Louise hayam took in martyr sir
heidak and her two sons it was only
meant to be temporary Louise is in the
process of becoming a foster carer and
needs her home back to help others
there's always been this deadline
looming and now we're both not sleeping
because there's no way on Earth I'm
Gonna Make Her homeless martyr has a job
here and hopes she can scrape together
the deposit she'll need to rent a house
but she's found landlords are reluctant
to rent to refugees I don't know what
will be happened with me and my children
Louise says she's also looked for
someone else to host Marta's family in
West Sussex but couldn't find anyone
with space it does feel like all the
responsibilities on our shoulders for
their welfare going forward
and
that's quite harsh and actually quite
shocking
the charity opora estimates that one in
ten refugees who've been hosted in
English households have moved out before
six months
Sky News also submitted Freedom of
Information requests to councils Across
the UK of those that responded three in
four said a relationship breakdown was
the most common cause for hosts wanting
guests to leave
some ukrainians have returned home but
Marta says it's still too dangerous for
her and her children to go back so with
no obvious solution and lots of
sleepless nights both she and Louise are
desperate for help Becky Cottrell Sky
News West Sussex